let's talk about the informational
interview my name is Martin McGovern and
I'm a career advisor here at Udacity and
recently we got a question from one of
our students who asked what is an
informational interview if you put
informational interview into Google
you're going to get a very long and
drawn-out answer something along the
lines of an informational interview also
known as an informational conversation
is a meeting in which a potential job
seeker seeks advice let's keep it simple
an informational interview is a
conversation with someone who is
currently doing the job that you wish
you had when it comes to actually going
on an informational interview the main
things that you have to keep in mind are
number one who are you reaching out to
number two what are you talking about
and number three what are you asking
them for let's dig a little deeper and
number one who do you reach out to
well you reach out to the person who has
the job you wish you had it's very
simple you go to LinkedIn you type in
the job title and boom it will filter
all the people who have that job title
and that is your initial list to reach
out to number two what are you going to
talk to them about a lot of times we
think it's about us and our job search
but the truth of the matter is is that
this is an informational interview we
want advice we want information we want
knowledge so you need to go in asking a
lot of questions about them not just
saying I want the job and number three
you have to be very careful with what
you're asking this person for when you
meet them for an informational interview
a lot of times people go in and just go
straight for the job I'm looking for
this can you help me but if you don't
have a good rapport set up already that
person might pull back so you want to do
is you want to make the conversation all
about them their job ask for their
advice and then at the end of the
conversation say if something were to
come up for the future would you be
willing to pass along my resume now
you're getting them to commit to a
future behavior which is much lower risk
than asking them to do something right
now
thank you so much for watching if you
have any questions or tips of your own
please
in the comments below and if you know
anyone who is searching for a job right
now tag them and let them know that
you're thinking about them we look
forward to answering many more of your
career questions in the future and wish
you all the best of luck in your job
search
[Music]